alors on à romagne sanchez qui est avec
nous un parcours stupéfiants c'est son
livre ancien dealer futurs médecins
quand et pourquoi vous avez commencé à
dire et vous avez quel âge romane âgé 32
ans 32 ans et vous avez dit les deux de
calage à quel âge de 16 à 18 ans quasi
de 16 à 18 ans pendant deux ans vous
étiez un dealer pourquoi comment comment
ça s'est passé quand vous vous êtes
retrouvé alors en fait j'ai commencé à
fumer du cannabis à l'âge de 12 ans 12
12 ans est dans la cour du collège ces
huit ans après doc gynéco et du coup
j'étais consommateurs pendant plusieurs
années pendant trois ans à peu près et à
16 ans quand je suis arrivé en première
j'ai avec des amis on a fait une bêtise
on a cassé un mur d'une école et on
s'est fait attraper et on devait
rembourser 1500 euros chacun d'accord du
coup passé mes parents qui ont payé et
ça me gêne un petit peu donc je voulais
les rembourser tout ça et je me suis dit
comment je pourrais gagner de l'argent
j'ai réfléchi je me suis dis la chose la
plus simple c'est c'était de vendre
voilà j'ai c'est ce qui met du shit
voilà du shit d'accord comment à la
sortie du collège chez moi au lycée
voilà enfin je vous le procurer comment
comment ça se passait au début c'est un
ami en que j'avais en commun qui
m'apportait des petites quantités
à des prix raisonnables et un jour il
m'a carrément amené à sevran scooter et
c'est là que j'ai découvert en fait que
dans les cités on ne pouvait acheter des
grandes quantités de cannabis à très bon
prix
vous avez commencé à faire votre marché
voilà j'ai j'ai dit à tous mes copains
que j'en avais et que j'essayais de
faire des bons prix donc forcément ça
les intéressait et voilà je leur disais
si tu as des copains battu leur dit et
puis très rapidement mon numéro à ne pas
circuler et ça a commencé comme si
j'avais gagné jusqu'à combien par mois
jeter dans les 1500 2000 euros à 16,17
on voit là par mois par mois en espèces
bien sûr voilà pas d'impôts madrid reste
on se doute bien la péta déclaration
c'est un milieu violent
alors vous avez vécu des choses
violentes
alors oui j'ai j'ai subi plusieurs
tentatives de racket
une fois c'était dans la cour du lycée
il ya deux mecs qui sont arrivés enfin
un qui n'étaient même pas au lycée il
été déscolarisés et un autre qui était
au lycée qui lui avait dit que j'avais
tout le temps plein d'argent sur moi
plein de stupéfiants et du coup ils se
sont dit bon bah on va aller le
le volet et je me suis battu avec eux
j'étais tout seul je vois je me suis
battu avec ses de ces deux gars là
j'avais un poing américain pour le coup
une autre fois pareil
un autre gars avec qui j'avais eu
quelques embrouilles à ce sujet là et un
jour il m'a vu passer dans ville et il a
appelé deux de ses potes et ils m'ont
rattrapé et là il a sorti un couteau
devant moi et moi pareil j'avais
toujours mon poing américain et on s'est
fait face bon finalement ils ont rien
fait mais bon ça aurait pu mal tourner
ce jour là alors ce que vous avez déjà
eu des problèmes avec la police
ou bien vous avez arrêté at-on ballet de
en fait j'ai arrêté parce que je sentais
que j'allais me faire attraper quand
j'avais 17 ans et demi à peu près et
effectivement à 18 ans bah ils m'ont ils
m'ont convoqué au commissariat et je me
suis fait arrêter
voilà j'ai fait 48 heures de garde à vue
et après je suis passé au tribunal
et alors vous avez écopé de quoi de j'ai
pris trois mois de prison avec sursis
avec une mise à l'épreuve de cinq ans
d'accord vos parents qui comme ils ont
agi qui se dit pas du tout quand je
suppose que vous étiez un dealer à 6,6
donc oui c'était away non mais c'était
compliqué c'est une époque que je
regrette fait
et voilà je ne suis pas fier et sûr
norris est bien d'en parler aujourd'hui
voilà oui bof on est au courant
bah oui parce que ils trouvaient des
bouts comme ça dans ma chambre et des
liasses de billets enfin j'avais des
fins voilà et vous on dit quoi
bah il me crier dessus il essayait de me
prendre mes affaires et tout ça et il
faut vraiment arrêter maintenant
oui c'est ça pardon il faut vraiment
arrêter maintenant oui oui bah oui je
sais ce qu'on dit d'habitude les bras
ap ap la police ah oui non ils n'ont pas
dénoncé par contre mais ils savaient
qu'ils avaient un dealer à la maison oui
mais c'est pas si évident que ça mais
voilà enfin je leur disais que
j'arrêtais mais en fait je continuais
fin voilà j'étais infernal quoi quand
vous avez été en garde à vue comment il
réagit ils ont été avait peur surtout en
fait j'avais peur pour moi ils avaient
peur que j'allais en prison c'était
inquiète coiffard alors quand on vous
écoute ce soir et il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui doit regarder avec cette
émission est très regardé chez les
jeunes moi j'ai envie de savoir surtout
pourquoi vous avez arrêté
et pourquoi faut pas le faire parce
qu'il ya plein de jeunes qui vont se
dire on gagner 1500 2000 euros par mois
qu'est ce qui vous a fait arrêter je
vais être honnête j'avais 17 ans à
l'époque et moi ce qui m'a fait arrêter
c'est la peur d'aller en prison afin de
me laisser arrêter par la police ou au
pire enfin je veux dire d'avoir des
problèmes avec d'autres mecs qui pour le
coup se sont beaucoup plus violents que
moi et voilà des peurs de que ça se
termine mal que vous avez peur pour
votre vie quelques fois oui bah quand
j'ai eu un couteau devant les yeux oui
c'est ça faisait un peu peur donc vous
avez arrêté du jour au lendemain qu'on
vous êtes fait arrêter ensuite vous avez
arrêté totalement
ah oui après j'ai repris un travail en
bep cuisine
bon après voilà j'ai fait plein de trucs
et aujourd'hui donc vous êtes médecin
oui je suis internes en médecine
générale
oui c'est incroyable voilà pour arrêter
tout ce que vous avez fait à vous bah
oui franchement oui je regrette parce
que bah c'est pas bien de vendre de la
drogue et j'ai perdu beaucoup de temps
mais j'ai fait du mal à mes parents je
me suis abîmé la santé je sentais
vraiment vous êtes habillé mais la santé
un petit peu mon ça va mais oui un petit
peu je pense que oui j'ai pas j'ai perdu
quand vous êtes vous êtes pour la
légalisation du cannabis ou franchement
c c'est une question qui est vraiment
très difficile à jouer en fait je suis
pour pour certains arguments et contre
certains arguments aussi voilà je ne
saurais pas me prononcer après moi il ya
des pays qu'ils le font visiblement ça
se passe plutôt bien donc je sais pas